if somebody's a gate agent for an
airline you pretty much want them to
have a finite mindset right you don't
want them to be also gushy gushy that
the plane never leaves the ground like I
I need I need a beginning a middle and
an end however I want them to be like
the Venn diagram still has a 10% of the
internet mindset because they understand
how I treat a customer actually still
matters in the infinite mindset because
I need you to come back not just I need
to not just get this plane out today I
need you to come back and fly with us
tomorrow so they you want them to have a
finite set but you want them to be aware
of the infinite mindset because you want
them to be aware that they're building
something that can outlast them and feel
a part of the just cause at the most
senior levels you want them almost
obsessed with the infinite mindset right
but they have to be aware of the finite
components that are important to keeping
the business running because they're
gonna make policy decisions they're
going to affect the frontline and they
have to know that too but you don't want
somebody in a senior senior senior job
who's obsessed with the finite because
then you get somebody in the CEO job
who's really a finance person and by the
way that's a little aside there you know
in all of the c-level jobs we put
somebody's Job Description in their in
their title CFO CMO CTO you're not good
at reading a balance sheet we don't make
you the CFO I don't even need to read
your resume and I know that what's a CEO
what exactly is an executive officer and
this is one of the problems we keep
promoting the wrong people into that job
because we don't really know what that
job does we need a new title CVO chief
vision officer someone who is the keeper
of the vision the holder of the vision
they are the final arbiter whether it's
worth the short-term sacrifice for this
finite gain in order to advance the
infinite we need CV o--'s and generally
the the the finite minded people that we
need in our companies those OP those
operators there's finance driven people
we need them to be aware of the infinite
game but they're probably not equipped
to be the CEO some of them can make the
adjustment but a lot of them can't so I
think you have to understand that that
we have to understand that finite is not
bad the problem is there's a context for
all the finite and what we've forgotten
as the cut is the fight is the context
the infinite game is the context within
which finite games exist they do not
happen in a vacuum
they're an infinite game is not just a
series of finite games it's not what it
is
every finite game must be used to
advance the infinite and we need people
to remember that and the the the leader
is the one who's reminding us of the
cause reminding us of the cause
reminding us of the cause so we all feel
like what we're contributing to and
helping to advance advance is the key
word there's no such thing as winning
there's only advancing
[Music]